author and columnist mark Stein joins us
tonight so you've traveled broadly and
you've written a lot about Russia the
Soviets and now the Russian government
over the decades did you ever even
suspect that they were clever enough to
promote our own bill of rights against
us no well they do play the long game
the Russian so for them to talk up the
Second Amendment if I follow Adam shifts
argument they're talking up the Second
Amendment so that we all shoot each
other which will save the emitter the
Russians the trouble of having to
conquer us this is brilliant
you know congressman swoll well this is
how stupid it is he he accused you of
McCarthyite tactics when he is the one
saying that you work for the Kremlin the
this this is so nuts he says also that
you're attacking the rule of law the
reason some of us are upset about this
is because it what is going on is an
assault on the rule of law yes an
American citizen who has not been
convicted of any crime and actually has
never even been charged with one has
nevertheless been under United States
surveillance on and off for half a
decade this guy's life is actually as
and reputation has been ruined and the
Democrats are okay with that because
he's just this this week's you useful
MacGuffin as Alfred Hitchcock used to
call it to distract people in the Russia
investigation it's an assault on the
rule of law and it reminds us of a very
important lesson which this memo is all
about that there's a very that there's a
point at which there's a legitimate
intelligence community and then there's
a point of which it becomes actually
secret police activities and what
they've done to this US citizen card a
page crosses well into the line I
believe of secret police activities well
it's it's certainly something that has
shaken a lot of people's faith in the
system and it's in a system that you
want to believe in in fact your
population needs to believe in in order
for the country to function so I wonder
though is this a fever dream that we're
gonna wake up from like 20 years from
now we'd be you know replaying the atom
shift tape and saying there was a
congressman who accused any who
disagreed with him of working for a
foreign power or will they not recover
well I would like to think so I would
like I would like to think that just as
Hollywood kind of gets it right 3040
years afterwards that the elderly Tom
Hanks and George Clooney will be will be
lining up to play Adam Schiff in movies
and and the even more elderly Meryl
Streep
will be playing the outrageous Nancy
Pelosi as she says that
congressman Nunez has broken the laws of
Congress and he should be going to jail
for it but at heart you know the
Democrats are doing this because this
isn't just a few rogue elements of the
permanent bureaucracy the two most
powerful factions in the Democrat
establishment the Obama administration
and the Clinton campaign were also tied
up with this every step of the way
including you know a whatever whatever
is title is the assistant deputy under
assistant deputy Under Secretary of
State this guy whiner Weiner who was
actually big buddies with Christopher
Steele on this Christopher Steele
himself is actually a very unusual
figure who supposedly quote retired from
mi6 unquote at the age of 44 and is
described in this memo as a longtime
asset of the FBI that's actually a
breach of the five eyes intelligence
sharing arrangement between the United
States and British Commonwealth
countries there's a lot of very weird
sinister and malodorous aspects and the
Democrats should stop throwing
distractions in the path by accusing you
of being a Russian agent well I just
want to say for the record how dare you
ask questions mark that's something we
do
no alone screaming agent - you must be a
question yeah thank you Mark mark Stein
Thank You Daka